hey guys my name is Jess is the 10th of
August and I've got some gaming news for
you Wednesday Bethesda marketing exec
Pete Hines has said that the oldest roll
6 is coming but not anytime soon Hines
has actually the same sentiment he made
back in June by saying the eldest roll 6
isn't in development we simply said we
would make it eventually he added
Bethesda is not a 2 button vending
machine where we first press Elder
Scrolls and then we press fallout I know
what they're working on for the next
decade and I think all of them are
things to get excited about for
different reasons and once they come out
folks will enjoy them for what they are
but those two have also expressed an
interest in creating more mobile games
and exploring virtual reality that were
yet to see what will come with that next
up quantum break is making the leap over
to steam in just over a month Microsoft
and Remedy announced that the time
manipulation heavy action game will
arrive on Steam come September 14 that
same day will also be available in a
retail version called quantum break
timeless collector's edition which
includes making all features a
soundtrack to posters 5 game discs and
premium packaging whatever that means
both editions will run you 40 bucks
fortunately for those of you still
denying that notification box telling
you it's time to upgrade to Windows 10
quantum break steam release will work
with Windows 7 and 8 the only caveat
being that you will need to be running a
64-bit version of your operating systems
hello games director Sean Murray has
told the Daily Star that if Nermin sky
were to run on the more powerful ps4
near it would fundamentally change the
gameplay experience
Mauri explained a full hour game it's
procedurally generated so more powerful
hardware doesn't just mean upgraded
textures or a higher framerate it means
we can fundamentally change the
experience he added the studio is able
to change huge things through their
patches including the density and
immersion of worlds and wealth types
that said no official decisions have
been made to bring no man skate to the
ps4
as yet be sure to stop by GameSpot for
stories on the evil within and Gears of
War 4 and apply again tomorrow for a
bunch more news